it seems Donald Trump May to some degree
see the writing on the wall
that he may not win the 2024 Republican
primary we've already speculated as have
a number of different writers is Trump
even going to make it to the Republican
primaries or will a lack of support all
but force him to bail maybe citing other
interests maybe citing health issues
before a single ballot is even cast in
the 2024 Republican primary well there's
another possibility that Trump does run
for president
but not within the Republican primary
and that seems to be what he is now
threatening to do
trumpist site encourages Donald to run
in a third party
and he seems down
former president Donald Trump this is
from Rolling Stone who through his
nightmarish red cat back into the ring
and launched a third bid for the White
House shared an article Wednesday that
suggested he run as a third party
candidate posting on Truth social
essential the social media platform he
started after being booted from Twitter
Trump promoted an article from
conservative publication American
greatness staying true to the site's
unofficial role as a trump mouthpiece
Dan
gellernter glendra gelern turn that's
difficult huh claimed that the RNC can
pretend Trump isn't loved by the base
anymore
and that Trump is still admired and even
loved by those who consider themselves
ordinary Americans
compared Trump to the late president
Teddy Roosevelt
and suggested the idea of uh running
third party although gulleringtoner
admits that Trump running as a third
party candidate would likely meet a
similar fate to Woodrow Wilson he
declared his allegiance to the former
president Trump then reposted that I
guess you could say he re-rothed it and
mediaite reports Trump appears to
threaten third party run to split the
Republican party in half we want the
Republican party to destroy itself
Democrats seem unable to destroy it and
in fact sometimes make very strange
decisions that seem to almost prop it up
but it would be great if the Republican
Party destroyed itself and a third party
run by Donald Trump would Splinter the
party and it would absolutely undermine
its own chances in future elections now
a key factor to consider when we think
about this is
if Trump runs third party what impact
does that have on Republican voters what
would the average Republican voter think
because you have these Trump supporters
that are fiercely loyal to an almost
cult-like degree
they would certainly follow Trump if he
ran as a third party candidate that
takes votes away from the Republican
party and we'll talk in a moment about
why that is so important that splits the
conservative vote and opens the door for
Democrats even with a mediocre candidate
whoever the candidate ends up being to
win elections you could also see the
Republicans that are less cult-like but
are sort of in the well we're not I'm a
conservative
but I'm not a trump person but I really
don't like Hillary I really don't like
Biden so I'm going to hold my nose and
vote for Trump that group that is
already sort of turned off by Trump's
rhetoric and by Trump's actions if Trump
runs third party that group of
Republicans will absolutely see it as
okay listen
I held my nose and I voted for Trump
over Hillary
and I voted for Trump over Biden but
that's because he was still within the
party I support now that Trump is
running third party that's too much for
me and I'll either stay home or just
vote for the Republican candidate even
if I know that it's an inevitability
that the with the vote split the
Democrat will win so it could also hurt
Trump with those reluctant
Trump voters that are really more
Republicans than they are Maga people
and then there could be the far-reaching
consequences for Republicans more
broadly if you have the vote split in
that way and some people stay home and
some vote third party for Trump will
they be as eager to go out and vote for
Republican candidates for the House of
Representatives will these folks who are
kind of disgusted by what might happen
within the Republican party if Trump
runs third party will they go out and
eagerly vote for Republican Senate
candidates so Trump running third party
could be a delightful disaster for the
Republican party not only at the
presidential level but also down ballot
now the math of it for those who may not
know or who need a refresher is very
simple the Trump third party run all but
ensures a democratic victory in the
United States much to my dismay I don't
like the electoral college system but
the way you win in the United States is
you have to get a majority of the
Electoral College votes that means that
based on population each state has a
different number of votes or you might
call them points you need 270 points or
votes to win and the only way you get
those in most States is by the only way
you get any in Most states is by winning
the state's popular vote
if Trump were to run as a third party
candidate it is likely that he would
pull enough votes away from the
Republican candidate that the Republican
candidate would lose but that he would
also not get enough votes to win himself
meaning that a state that might have
gone
55-45 to Trump could end up going
something like you know just to make it
up here 45 percent to the Democrat
35 percent to Trump and 30 percent to
the Republican candidate Most states do
not have a 50 percent runoff threshold
Georgia does but not all states do
um and so Trump running third party
would all but seal the deal for the
eventual Democratic nominee when you
split the right-wing vote you make it
easier for Democrats to win and you make
it easy for Democrats to win with not
even a majority of the vote the real
question becomes is Trump dumb enough
not to understand the reality of the
math and or is Trump narcissistic enough
to think that this is a good idea I hope
the answer is yes to both
and uh as I've said many times before
as an observer of politics I mean I'm
talking about myself now
um I don't care about the Democratic
party I'm not a Democrat I just vote for
whoever I think is going to do the best
job but I recognize the Dynamics the
party dynamics that exist I would love
to see the Republican Party damage
itself in exactly this way whether Trump
will do it whether the Republican party
has some Fail-Safe remains to be seen
let me know your thoughts and folks make
sure as we wrap up 2022 and get into
2023 make sure you were subscribed to
the YouTube channel it costs nothing it
affirms what we do and it helps us in
YouTube's algorithm we're fighting for 2
million YouTube subscribers it is not a
a level reached by too many Progressive
YouTube channels help us get there more
than 3 million of you regularly watch
our Clips but don't subscribe nothing
changes for you you can still eat
whatever food you like you can still
watch whatever shows you want you just
hit subscribe and you get us a little
bit closer to that 2 million threshold
we'll take a quick break and be back
right after this with the final show of
the year